we have one bit of old business that has
become new business because a certain
old man quarterback would like us to get
off his lawn
miles simmons has found a very unlikely
ally
in tom brady because tom brady
not a fan of the rules that have
dramatically expanded the numbers that
can be worn and it's not just
single digit expansion as it dawned on
me today when i looked more closely and
thought
more thoroughly or at all about what
this means
you're going to have expansion of
linebackers from
one all the way up to 59 so you can have
linebackers in the teens in the 20s and
the 30s and the 40s
you can have running backs in the 80s
you can have tight ends from one
all the way up to 49 and then 80 to 89
previously tight ends were just 80 to 89
so it is going to be revolutionary
for the nfl tom brady thinks it's stupid
tom brady thinks it's going to result in
a lot of bad football
i still don't understand that miles
since you're the
anti-single digit number person
within pft i want you to make the case
as to why from a football standpoint not
cosmetic but from a football standpoint
this is a bad idea
well i think that if you're looking at
it like tom brady is looking at it then
you can say it's going to be more
difficult to figure out what the
personnel groupings are
on either side of the ball right if you
are an offensive player and i think to
tom brady's point
if you're looking at this and he's been
doing this for 20 years so i can
understand it from his perspective
why all of a sudden he doesn't want to
go out there and say number nine is the
mic
like that should be a 50 right that's
something that he's been doing for
really 20 years so it doesn't want to be
number nine he doesn't want it to be
23 is the mic or 34 is the mic that's
weird it's just not necessarily
something that you have seen in the past
so i get it from that standpoint and
you know if you're looking at it as if
you're going to say all right i want to
be able to tell
immediately if these guys are a nickel
if these guys
are in dime if they're in their base
package it may be a little bit harder to
tell
because you're not going to see the same
numbers however
i guess you asked me to make the
argument for what brady's talking about
now i'm going to make the argument
against it look
you're watching film all week so a lot
of times guys when they're in the locker
room and they're
when before when we still were able to
go into the locker room and we weren't
just doing these things on zoom
and they would talk about different
players on other teams they would refer
to them
as numbers right so you know if you were
talking about
whoever it is and this cornerback is on
the other team usually you'd say yeah 23
is really good we know that he does a
lot of things with press coverage and
all that
so i they're gonna know who guys are you
know and brady may say well they're
going to be
it's going to be easier for them to get
off a blitz toward me like
maybe but you're still going to know who
it is because you've been watching film
all week
and no matter what if you're tom brady
you've seen the blitz before so i think
tom brady is going to be okay
well and that's the thing that bothers
me about this two things bother me about
it first of all
you have studied film all week you know
who the players
are you know who number five is you know
he's a linebacker you know that there's
uh a an outside linebacker who wears 17
like rashad weaver from pitt wants to do
at the next level and
you better make sure you're classified
as a linebacker not a defensive end
because if you're a defensive end fewer
numbers available
the other thing that bothers me is this
why
are we just hearing about this after
the change is made it's not like it was
some secret proposal
remember a few years ago when they put
in the rule about lowering their helmet
and making contact with an opponent
and that just came out of the blue that
was literally a rule that they drafted
up at night at the league meetings and
didn't tell anyone about until the
owners voted on it there was no
opportunity for anyone to say
maybe this isn't a good idea and i think
they wanted it that way
after the fact people were saying maybe
this isn't a good idea and we've seen
that maybe it wasn't
this was out there it was a trending
topic it was a big deal guys on his team
leonard fournette
talking about moving to number seven
guys were discussing this
this was well known in nfl circles and
i don't know do i expect tom brady to be
plugged in on what's happening in the
nfl well yeah greatest nfl player of all
time i'd like to think he knows what's
going on in the sport that he's mastered
right the fact that he's complaining
about it
after the rule has been passed rings
hollow to me
because he knew or should have known
about it before and should have said
something i don't want to pick on albert
breer but i saw a tweet from albert
breer
saying oh yeah there were coaches who
had this concern well why don't you say
something about it why didn't somebody
point this out so we could have a
reasoned debate
instead of just oh okay kansas city
wants to have more numbers available and
you know
teams of retired numbers and you get
into all these expanded rosters and
practice squads and it becomes a pain in
the butt
fine there was no pushback there was no
counter i heard no sort of counter to
this
so it's it's stunning to me that tom
brady swoops in
out of the blue and is complaining about
it after it's already been passed
tom you should have said something
tuesday i'd like to think that tom
brady's got
the cachet to get people's attention
maybe he didn't say anything about it
because he knew he wouldn't
cause it from from being enacted i don't
know but
i sure would have had a lot more
good to say about the position if he'd
chimed in
before it was too late the cavalry
cavalry arrived
a little too late on this one miles
how much you want to bet if he had said
this on tuesday or monday
then the buccaneers would have voted
against it on wednesday right i mean
like that's the kind of influence
that tom brady has and he's earned that
influence especially after going to
tampa bay
and winning a super bowl like he did but
i think you're right look
i don't know that any real trepidation
expressed by coaches or players or
anybody
would have changed the outcome of this
but this has been
universally praised except for people
like me
by pretty much everybody right i mean
you were into it everybody else in our
pft group text was into it
all the players seem to be really into
it and really if you look at it it's
basically
just like the college game i mean guys
have all kinds of different numbers in
college
and different teams still end up winning
a lot of games and it doesn't seem to
mess things up there either so
i think i'm going to the other side on
this i think i told you the other day
i'm like
in the acceptance stage of grief so now
i don't know what really is after that
but i
probably am there especially because
like look when you
when you're calling it dumb just because
guys are gonna have different numbers
at this point it's like dude the rules
already there man i don't know it's
time to move on to something else the
the reality of whatever strategic
benefit there may have
i i i'm not buying it in part because
you mentioned that in college the
numbers have been all over the place for
a long time
if there was any benefit if there was
any potential confusion
nick saban would have been using it as a
sword by now i i really don't
think that there is a benefit i don't
get it
i really do think tom brady even though
his body
has been impervious to aging i think
you know under that that tb12 manicured
exterior
he's the old dude sitting on his porch
with a cooler full of beer saying get
off my lawn
he he he's he's like the it's like the
portrait of dorian gray
but the aging is happening under his
skin he's secretly an 85 year old man
who is pissed off at the world and
doesn't like all these newfangled rules
that's my only explanation for it miles
well he's 127 in football years
basically so
i think it makes sense when he's done
this for as long as he's done it
at a high level as he's played it at for
him to say i don't want this to change i
don't like this
and get off of my lawn i frankly
understand it from his perspective i
really do
because when you've been calling out the
same number as the mic
for 20 years going into his 21st season
you don't want to change that
unfortunately i mean for him unless you
know these guys aren't really superstars
there probably aren't going to be that
many dudes
who end up changing their numbers you
know because they're gonna have to pay
to buy out all of that inventory in
order to do it so
maybe he retires after this year but i
don't know
i i've got a story that may be coming
soon on pft on that topic
of of having to write a check and just
how large of a check it could be
i'm working on it trying to get
clearance to go forward with
it got some phone calls to make once
we're done here today
meanwhile though we will move on it is
strange that tom brady would pick this
of all hills
to die on because he's never been that
guy he's never been
has he been has he ever been complain
about rules guy
i don't think so i mean they changed
rules for him right
i mean you know you couldn't hit the
quarterback low on all those different
types of things so
one really didn't change there's one
rule they didn't change there's one rule
they enforced very aggressively
against tom brady that's the only rule
he ever would have complained about
that don't and don't and don't throw
away your cell phone
uh don't under inflate the balls and
don't throw your cell phone into the
river those are two rules very important
that
would apply to tom brady before this one
and i i just i don't i don't see it i
think of all the players in the league
the fact that it's him makes it even
more compelling
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports